remember i was like i can't swim dude
when we were doing fury i was like and
you were like man i'll i'll teach you
you know like and this dude like a
killer whale floated like all the way
across underwater then he floated back
like he shot back then he went back i've
never in my life seen anybody better in
the water than you
[Music]
what does it mean to be a warrior
that's a that's a big label you know um
yeah i think
i would look at it like what does it
mean to be a better man
really and and that's that development i
don't think ever stops um i think we're
always working on it whether we're
fathers you know brothers sisters
community members we're part of
organizations or corporations or
whatever it is you know it's all about
continuing to cultivate yourself
and and being open to alternative
narratives too is i think it's so easy
you know today
in in the state of our country and and
being as polarized as it is is it's so
easy to choose a side that's easy
you know
my conversations with my friends that i
love
um
you know
many of the conversations we have is
about kind of sitting on the fence
you know and being open to
varying
opinions and dialogue on issues
where does that come from i mean the
ability because
sort of sort of not flag waving from
either side because no one's going to
think for me that's right so it comes
from and that because you've seen enough
well it's
you you go overseas and you you have an
idea what real destitution is what real
poverty is
right um what real suffering is under
tyranny
or oppression and you come home and you
love your country and you say wow what
vast abundance we have right we got work
to do right um we certainly have a lot
of things that we've got to address here
we got to be adult about it we have to
look at our problems for what they are
but you have to be able to sit there and
not let any organization or corporation
provide you their opinion
and let that sit with you
you've got to be able to challenge
yourself and you've got to be able to
say hold on a second
um
you know what what's the alternative
point of view on this um
and
even grossly like people will
take this for what it is but if you if
you look at
um some of the greatest minds in our
country um political scientists or
um
you know people who are working in
foreign affairs yeah they have studied
the communist manifesto they break it
down that's part of their you know
graduate studies sure doesn't mean
they're communist right they're looking
at the opposing points potentially we
can we can we can get something out of
this we can why is the other why is the
other person thinking this way right
what seeds or ideologies
um
that have that have set this system or
the civilization up the way it is
so i can deconstruct it and then
deepen my sense of conviction or
empathize and show compassion for their
state of being and their way of living
so the pursuit uh the the hunger for
knowledge the pursuit of of growth to
deny that and sort of just say it's my
way or the highway literally means to
cut off the potential to to to grow or
to learn or to be better it's too simple
yeah you know it's too simple to say
you know
the democrats and the liberals are
destroying this country right it's it's
it's cheap right cheating yourself right
most americans want the same things
we're deeply divided country currently
um it doesn't sit well with me
um we've got a lot of great people from
all different backgrounds and all
different walks of life doing beautiful
things we're not paying attention to
those beautiful things right now
there's a lot of discourse and discord
in this country that's been sown by
political talking points
and i think we've lost the focus
that the health of our nation depends on
our civic ties yep it um
and it's been eroding for a little while
now and i think everyone needs to take
take stock in inventory right now sit
back
reevaluate why they're so pissed off
right and say hold on how do you do that
how do you reevaluate why i i mean like
how do you [ __ ] do that i mean like
people are angry right they're they're
angry for either what they have or what
they don't have what they feel like they
deserve how they've been slighted um but
but i guess how do you reach that person
well i think that it just comes down to
um again taking stock if you're so
pissed off and you're so angry
at one
demographic
in this country
take pause
sit back
walk away from the situation and go
spend some time with mother nature yeah
yeah go get some perspective first of
all yeah yeah so you know it relates to
policing and and certainly um you know
my perspectives on on law enforcement
and my understanding of
the tremendous task that they have to
undertake um going back to the military
and we talk about you know the special
operations community
and um
how many different disciplines we're
responsible for you look at the scope of
practice of a 1950s beat cop well i'm
there to walk down the street make sure
nobody jaywalks keep traffic in line and
any drunks put them in a cab and set
them on the way home that's right
what is the job of a law enforcement
officer today
vastly more difficult vastly more
disciplines you're talking about
terrorism you're talking about domestic
violence you're talking about
you know whether it's intoxicated people
and the drug issue um
it's it's a litany of issues that they
deal with on a daily basis that they
have to navigate and it's a tremendous
task you know one of the things that i
saw early on in my career being a part
of the organization that i'm a part of
is i began to see some performance
failure
um when we operated on the fire ground
on fires and it had to do with stress um
and something that i'm very familiar
with is
you know when we go back to world war ii
and we have our ideas of world war ii
whether it's implanted on us from books
or saving private reining or banner
brothers or the pacific right
one other thing that the general
population doesn't understand is for the
most part we were asking very young men
to go on these ultraviolet situations
with very limited training right hey
rely on one another we're going to get
through this right
and the military really took um
really took the performance of their
soldiers especially during the world war
ii era
um to heart the fir one of the very
first battles so to speak in north
africa after the bombing of pearl
harbors we send an armored division into
north africa and during that skirmish
the germans had attacked british and
american positions and the americans
left their position
the lieutenant general at that time
hunkered down in his bunker there was no
communication communication failure and
this is the first time our soldiers were
shelled and shot at and they didn't know
what to do
so they really began to evaluate that
and then comes patton and he says well
first of all training needs to be way
more rigorous we're not preparing these
guys for this fight
and how do we increase soldiers
performance so the military in the dod
has poured
tens of million dollars into
um
really the performance of the soldier
and how do we
inoculate our soldiers to the point
where if we put them in these highly
stressful situations that they're
prepared to perform right and perform
very well and look at where we are now
right like if you go from world war ii
to vietnam to korea um to the first gulf
to where we are now and you look at
performance rates of people it's because
so much money and effort has been poured
into
a lot of very stressful training that's
indoctrinated into every module of
training
and
the military can afford to do that right
they've got the budget right now you
take
a 20 year old 22 year old who goes
through an 18-week
police academy
and goes into an organization that may
be large
like lapd yep or small like rural
mississippi right right what devices do
they have right to draw upon that's what
they know but it also depends on their
budget right um and it also depends on
how much
uh they want to indoctrinate and can
indoctrinate those candidates with
stress right in in these particular high
threat scenarios so you
you take a young law enforcement officer
uh who's going to learn and we all learn
in state dependent learning which means
the state of consciousness that i'm in
will determine how i perform in a
similar scenario you got to create it in
training i can't learn to box by
punching a bag that's right i need to be
punched in the face yep yep yep right
yep so part of the military training is
is
we're going to teach you a skill and
you're going to become confident or
competent in that skill we want to we
want you to show us that you're
proficient now i'm going to add
complexity to that skill now i'm going
to add distractions to that skill now
i'm going to add sleep deprivation and
clerk restriction to that skill now i'm
going to add physical fatigue to that
skill now i'm going to keep you awake
for days in mission planning and i want
you to go exercise all of these
different skills and then you're going
to go practice this mission and in the
process where you may get into a scrap
right and the whole thing is designed
for you to be able to perform in these
chaotic environments
do our does our law enforcement
community have that afforded to them
right do they have the capability to put
their students through
very rigorous
types of training that will prepare them
to
de-escalate
deal with these issues and then
ultimately when they do get into a
violent situation know when to turn it
off
i've contained the threat
and since the threat is now contained
i've got to dial down with my breathing
that's right and i've got to build in
composure
and that's the thing is composure
isn't taught
composure is earned
so the more you get into the boxing ring
how many times are you nervous when you
first started of course
and then you start to find your rhythm
in the box right and then you meet a
different fighter right and you have to
adapt and you build in composure
right yeah and it's earned of course
right so we have to be able to look at
people who are looking to defund law
enforcement
i say that's the exact wrong thing to do
we need to look at and evaluate how
large is their training department per
capita per officers in the field so like
la sheriffs and some of the training
officers that i spoke to there
it's a
grossly disproportionate amount of field
training officers per people in the
field they have 10 000 officers in the
field they have you know
maybe dozens and a couple dozen
you know five six dozen training
officers
um here your rounds go to the range
right and then you've got another six
thousand that are in corrections in
their prisons right
your we need to reevaluate and say no we
need more money for these law
enforcement agencies to expand their
training departments that can teach
de-escalation but also know when to
recompose yourself that when you're in
these violent situations
that you're through your breathing
and through
through that initial adrenaline rush and
this cortisol dump from your sympathetic
nervous response system into these fight
modes that you can regain composure
and that all goes back to that state
dependent learning i've been here before
i'm familiar with this before i've
hardwired this into my system this is
when i should turn it off that's right
the threat is now contained
we've detained this person everyone is
safe i've evaluated the environment
right if i need to turn it back on i can
turn it back on if i need to turn it
back off and those are the things in my
opinion that need to get exercised right
all to better the performance of our
community policing
fund them more
bring in some of these military experts
that can help them deal and start to
inoculate
um
you know some of these smaller
organizations that do exist out there
take you know my buddies from la
sheriff's retired guys and
pump them into you know these rural
areas
and teach them because these these guys
have a tremendous amount of experience
it's a tremendous amount of wisdom from
their job that really care about people
but
throughout their life and throughout
their career they know when to turn it
off that's right and if you've never
been in a scrap before it's like
you
gonna be a law enforcement officer so
guess what
you're going to get a lot of scraps but
we're going to prepare you for it that's
right because we want you to be able to
think under those stressful conditions
do you feel like you have ma
when you talk about sort of uh
de-escalation and understanding your
surroundings you have a mastery of that
would you say you achieved that in
training or did it take
it takes it's ongoing anything is
perishable right like and i wouldn't say
i've mastered it by any
but like if i go to let's say jiu jitsu
i know i'm gonna get my ass kicked in
the dojo and it's a wonderful thing and
it's humbling but at the same time it's
helping me stay with your breath control
your breath
you know counter here and
me controlling my breath in these
moments where i may get choked out
you know or i may have to tap
is it allows me to exercise that calm
and in those calm states i
have more available to me
cognitively right i have more tools that
i can draw upon if i let stress get the
better of me because i can't control my
breathing and i can't think my way out
of something right
i'm a goner but again training then is
looking for situations to get
uncomfortable and looking to [ __ ]
yourself up so to try to get better and
deal with them as they come in whatever
keeps you humble man like you said if
it's a big wave out there right if it's
nature spending time with nature
if it's you know
being in uncomfortable conversations if
it's going and training you know it's
it's always a good thing there's all
these wonderful tools out there that
will humble us and
um you know just also try and spend your
time with smarter human beings i don't
know about that brother what is the
difference between sort of de-escalation
sort of having a physical
maybe not mastery but a good handle on
yourself in in in terms of staying aware
of your surroundings uh assessing a
situation but what about morality does
morality play into that does it play
into it as a soldier is there ever a
time where you say you know i i know
this is being asked of me but this is
not right so i'm not gonna do that
you know
i think as it relates to law enforcement
it's kind of
you know
officer to officer right if you've got a
150 pound young hispanic officer versus
the the guy who's 225
you know
former like linebacker in college who's
now a sheriff somewhere you know it
there's the letter of the law and the
spirit of the law right um can can the
can the 225 pound sheriff exercise the
letter of law
yep
right can 150 pound you know female
hispanic sheriff or law enforcement
officer can she exercise the letter of
law all the time she's got to be smart
she's got to weigh the situation out
right she's gonna it's the spirit of the
law is anyone in immediate danger is
this if if i really get into it with
this person right now how is this going
to turn out
yeah i need to call for backup there's
all these tools you can use but
um
you know
there's it's a tall order you know for
our law enforcement community that
receives very little love like i'm a
firefighter and we got kids coming up to
the truck every day
there's a lot of love hey it's a fire
truck it's a fire truck you know there's
people coming by the station every day
and it's a wonderful experience and i
feel
for our law enforcement brothers and
sisters out there because they do not
receive that from the community
um certainly from politicians at times
they're always the whipping boy that's
it and it's been a pretty acute shift i
mean there's always been sort of tension
but [ __ ] man i mean it's been acute now
where you know we had we had jerry who
you know we had him on here and he's
talking about you know
the the the community that he's been
serving for you know decades going into
restaurants that always gave him they
don't want him in there anymore and to
sort of
be approached with that through
because of the the unbelievable mistakes
of
you know the worst element of them it's
it's uh it's
it's staggering it is is it you know and
i think that if we
community-wide
you know
the compassion that we're asking of our
countrymen to show an an impoverished
community or a community that suffers
that if we can open that lens also to
law enforcement's like what do they need
that's right to be better that's right
right it's not what you take away that's
right there's there's no solution in any
of that that's right right what did they
need and what can we provide them so
that we can be better so that's right
right and
i can understand i can understand the
fervor that comes from you know what
you're disrespecting law enforcement
[ __ ] that uh yeah you're disrespecting
the flag like i can understand it but
like there is an evolutionary step
that's above that that that says we can
be both we can say respect law
enforcement and we can also say hey
let's listen let's listen to what's
going on with these communities let's
look at this honestly and authentically
and have the courage to try to get
better like you you can do both and i
think that it's just
it's it's too easy to go to a place
of anger
that never works it's always you got to
go to a place of trying to understand
trying to converse trying to connect and
um these are just qualities i feel like
that that aren't being that that aren't
being pushed to the forefront right now
it's just it's too easy like what's
perpetuated is to be reactive right
if you look from a very psychological
perspective of what the intent of the
news organizations are there to do
are they there to provide you
information
are they there to get you to react and
if you do react you'll keep watching
take stock of that yeah do your own
inventory clean your own house and say
why am i reacting to this all the time
why am i looking at this and getting
upset all the time
is this making me a better human being
is this improving my life or is this
just stoking and the embers and the
flames that exist within me because
they've tapped into the very base nature
of my human being
and that's both sides and you walk away
and you're pissed off
right and if it's on the tv at the fire
station i turn it off yep yeah like you
know go turn on the nasa network and
watch the international space station
spin around the planet okay let's let's
hold on everybody look at a picture of
your kids the conversation i have with
this young man today um
really had to do with his understanding
of the military
um and what's been presented to him in
his life
and
he
basically understood the military as a
political organization
um that served a mission of war
and i don't think that most people
understand that the majority of what the
military does
it's humanitarian right
if you look at what's happened with
recent typhoons earthquakes
um just in the last 10 15 years
the military is always present
if you look at the surplus of food that
we have in this nation and
what we're doing for the impoverished
parts of the world and delivering food
to create some stability and provide
security
food security for some of the countries
that's the military's mission for the
most part and there's a tremendous
amount of job satisfaction and reward
that comes from that when serving in the
mill in the military i'm part of
something bigger than myself i'm
providing people
the very necessity to live
and
what's really causing the discord in
this country
and breaking americans apart
i think there's various layers to that
um
but i think it starts with turning off
the news whatever news network you
listen where do you get your news
uh
i i try not to dive into it too much i
try to go international
it's a broader perspective
it's a it's a very objective look at
america
um and i could say with 100 certainty
and confidence as well amongst my peer
group
you know when people thought the arab
network al jazeera was a propaganda
machine to them to a certain extent it
you know it was
but so is american news
they were studying al jazeera they were
they were
you know ingesting le monde out of
france and der spiegel out of germany
and mainly bbc
bbc's public public funded right um and
npr is public funded yes so if you're
paying attention
to human interest stories and human
stories you're right like these these
are about our people
you know and and
and things are always in flux and things
are always going to change but
you know i can all like all i got to do
is protect my dirt and my family and
then
whatever means i have necessary you know
try and make people's lives better
around me because
brother we're blessed i've been
renovated
from your time overseas and in your
experience in in either the enemy or the
locals that that live there did you
learn anything about
being a better soldier about being a
better man by them and if there is
anything that sticks into mind what
would that be
you know i think
one thing that comes to mind
specifically with you know iraq is you
know you have a country that's been
under the the fist of saddam hussein for
30 years
and i think one thing that always
strikes me is the resiliency of the
human spirit
um for people that have suffered for so
long under that type of rule
um
to still ingratiate themselves and
invite you into their home there's a lot
of unknowns when you're you know
6'4 carrying a large weapon
um and a lot of uncertainty in their
lives are we there to occupy are we
imperialist that some people say we are
and still to break bread with them
and to open yourself up and to them just
as much as they've opened themselves up
to you
and to share those meals
and in those cultures and those ancient
cultures uh throughout mesopotamia and
the middle east you know breaking bread
um
you know
is sacred it's it's uh the hospitality
and the honor
of sharing a meal with a stranger
is
something i think that we're missing in
this country
yeah you know do you just say no please
come in let me feed you totally let me
provide you sustenance yeah and and that
to me was so humbling and
something i wish we did a little a
little bit more of in this country you
know you know love this country
through and through but um
god i would love to see some people on
on either side of the aisles here you
know share some space with one another
yeah get some laughs yeah absolutely man
again my experience with gossip yourself
very open-minded very hungry
um to learn uh very empathetic
we where do you feel like the state what
like what's the political discourse in
that community
i don't know i i don't get a sense of it
it's always about the mission
i think if you do create
um you know certainly some waves in a
community um you're you're going to
isolate yourself really really quick how
so um well you've if you're making a
stand politically right it's an a
political organization right we're
serving the constitution you take an
oath you take a vow right to the ideals
of the nation um that's what you're
there to serve right um you're not to
serve any personal agenda because
you got to learn really quick and about
you right um and if and if you just
can't get over yourself you'll find
yourself
yeah and to to what extent do you think
sort of sensitivity or or political
correctness where does that play into it
you know where's the line between
empathy and sensitivity
um i guess that's that that's the first
question do you see a line i no but what
i do see is is like i think we're we're
now at this stage where um
you know the the extreme left and the
extreme right have been holding the
microphone for an extended period of
time
there's so many great people out there
sure the good people out there and the
wiser people out there
they need to start grabbing the
microphone they see they need to start
getting engaged
we need them to step forward um the
subject matter experts in different
fields and we need to give them a say
yeah um because i think that's what
people are really hungry for that's my
lens that's my perspective agree with it
or disagree with it but uh ultimately i
think people want something very genuine
something that comes from the heart
something that's very authentic
yeah right and
and to provide people with a sense of
hope of a sense of calm sure right that
um
authentic sometimes gets gets i think if
you i think people confuse sort of just
being being sort of uh
you know you know acting with reckless
abandonment or or just being different
is authentic and and i think that that's
different from being true
to to who you actually are you know i
think a lot of people make the mistake
of confusing kindness for weakness yeah
you know i i think that's a grave
mistake because um
some of the most incredible is your
words warriors um that you've met in
your life and the people that are
serving overseas right now are some of
the most gentle kind loving spirits
absolutely um
and exercise their tremendous amount of
humility in their lives when it comes to
it you know the people that are seeking
something and are searching for
something whether that's a deeper sense
of purpose and meaning in life is
it's right there it's right there in
front of you like if you want to get
involved and you want
you know to find
[Music]
let's say your your tribe or your clan
it it it just takes effort it's right
there in front of you go across the
street go into a neighborhood that needs
help you want fulfillment it comes
through other human beings it's not in a
trophy it will never be about a trophy
it will never be about accomplishment it
will never be about your bank account
right you know you want wealth
build friendships that's right and build
experiences and and really challenge
yourself with those experiences take
some chances yeah failure is universal
sure everyone has failed everyone has
fallen on their faces
and grossly and
humble leaders will take the chance on
you
because they know that they've failed
themselves that's right i've failed in
my career and people have recognized it
i almost lost my dream job
but it took a leader with humility to
say
now that because you failed you won't
make that mistake again so i know
the guys in your unit will be safer
and i said and i literally going in that
meeting it was already like i'm done i'm
done i'm done i made this grave mistake
and he knew in his own wisdom and his
own experiences like hold on
there's something to gain from that
failure there's a hundred percent of
course and keep trying of course trying
and keep trying there are people all
over the world that would love to come
to the united states there's less
bureaucracy there's more opportunity
and our english friends right when we
spend some time in england together you
know i just
you know i used to ask what do you think
about america
and
more times than not that you say i love
the american can do it [ __ ]
can-do
mentality like you guys just have it in
your back pocket that's right you want
to do something i can do it i i think
it's such an amazing such a vital
experience to get your ass overseas and
and really spend time and and and not
you know as much as on your own as you
as as you can because i think you'll
appreciate and love this country so much
more and see how uh you know the
american spirit there's literally
nothing like it and there is there's
nothing like it and it'll get america
appreciation you want to you want to
appreciate your country like american
appreciation starts with going overseas
and don't go somewhere you know
in a developed country yeah broaden your
horizons get some experience with some
french cuisine or whatever
but and enjoy it but go somewhere that
has very little to nothing and
see how good those people are and how
good they treat each other and how
welcoming they are to you
and they get by with so little
but more than anything they could buy
with themselves
and you look and you say
man we have so much back home we've just
been taking some stuff for granted yeah
and it's a good way to get uncomfortable
and getting uncomfortable and shaking
all that out of your system getting him
some perspective is i think everything's
valuable everything and so so tell me
you know i i told you i had my my little
brother on here and he was talking about
um
you know it's it's something we we talk
about a lot here empathy and compassion
and and and he was talking about in in
being a surgeon
and how you know really good surgeons
you know people to kind of talk about
surgeons as sort of being divorced from
their feelings and how you have to you
know kind of go in there and
you just got to be able to turn it off
and
he was sort of explaining but to be
really great you have to also be able to
turn it on and you've got to really be
able to get to know and understand and
let your patients and their families
into your heart to really understand
what it is that they need um you know
you and i have talked a little bit um
uh in the past about um i think you call
it like the beast like the beast in
inside of you and turning the beast on
and off um what is that
what does that entail and like can you
talk about that a little bit
yeah you you know it's um
if you're going
to or potentially going to inflict
extreme violence against other human
beings
there has to be a very aggressive side
of yourself
akin to
without the aggression of your brother
hey i have the surgical tools in my hand
it is my duty to save this person's life
i have to perform right now
right he's removing a cancer
um not to dehumanize the enemy but in
the same token that ideology is a cancer
i have to remove that cancer
right i have to apply a scalpel to that
not a big old sledgehammer right i'm not
going to create a big wide swath of a
mess here
but i have to apply that and
one tool is aggression right but if
that's sustained for too long that's
going to damage the human being
you know what i mean
so being able to turn that off and
re-center yourself
is something i think that the
individuals have to discover is what
tools do you use to turn the human body
back on
uh initially
um
initially it was nature you know
spending a lot of time with the ocean
underwater spear fishing or diving it
was complete silence i could feel like i
was flying through the kelp forest
um surfing
um
i i found a lot of peace with family and
friends at the kitchen in the kitchen
preparing food
um and and having that community
um
even though i didn't feel as necessarily
close to my own family as i did to my
teammates at the time because of the
experiences i had
and then just knowing that at some point
what i was trying to do wasn't working
and
[Music]
by making myself vulnerable to other
people that could help me navigate
[Music]
you know where i was in my life
and opening myself to receive care and
help um
was transformative
it was through other human beings that
invested in veterans in different
veterans group and law enforcement and
firefighters that
have experienced a tremendous amount of
trauma in their lives
and sh having those shared experiences
with with those groups
was incredible i got to go out and
escort
and share space with a bunch of veterans
law enforcement and firefighters
at a program called save a warrior
which was in ohio
um and i and as an escort and they said
hey kevin do you want to sit through the
indoctrination and the intake and i said
i'd love to yeah you know hold space for
other people
and then going through this process i
really loved what i was hearing
and in the process you know they kind of
surprised me and said you want to stay
for the week
and i got to stay for the week
and it was incredible because
you know one of the the sacraments there
was about you know there's so much shame
and guilt applied to being vulnerable
for a man
in today's society
um
and they explained to you the
physiological effects of hyperfocus
hypervigilance hyperaggressions for
sustained periods of time the brain
changes
how do we create balance well there's
tools that we can use like meditation
but there's also methods to heal
um and tears are an incredible um vessel
in that process just to sit and watch
men be vulnerable with one another to
share their trauma and to exercise that
i mean john one of the most profound
experiences i've had in my life
there's a gentleman that sat in a circle
that grew up in an abusive home
physically sexually mentally abusive
home
with drug addicts
he decided to escape it you know failing
out of high school decided to escape it
joined the army went overseas lost a
bunch of people in his unit came home
um in the process lost his young son
um to suffocating in the crib because
his wife was on drugs at the time
and then you know
um and then contracted ms so he's like
i'm done like life just has not been
fair to me he goes and he shared with
everyone and he said look you know
i'm
this is my last shot like i'm just
letting you guys know yeah but
throughout the week he put in every
single effort as a human being to make
himself as vulnerable as possible and
just let go of that trauma and open up
in tears just all week poured out of
this guy and in the process john i
watched his skin color changed i watched
his eye color change i watched his
posture change i watched him go through
horse therapy
it was incredible yeah like it was
metamorphosis
yeah and the love and support that he
received from the staff members and the
shepherds that were there and then from
the group
um
and it was all because he just made
himself vulnerable and he needed help
and he asked for help and he's and he
received the help and he received a lot
of you recognize that as the the courage
that that takes that is such a straight
it takes so much courage
ancient cultures knew this before our
ancient warriors whether native
americans their native or i'm sorry
naked greek warriors you know before men
came home from war there were rituals
that they had to go through exercising
those demons because society and the
civilization knew
that if you didn't provide a platform
for this trauma that they experienced
to
uh
to be exercised right
then they would bring that home and the
community the communal qualities of that
civilization depended on the health of
these men right right right and so what
rituals do we have in place now well um
you can board the plane first hey
everyone in the stands the baseball game
stand up and celebrate our veterans it's
not doing anybody any good right you
know it's it just takes space and it
takes that year it takes listening it
takes professional help but it takes
love you take a plant if that if a plant
is dying in the corner because it
doesn't have sunlight or water what do
you do with it
put it in the sunlight you give it water
you're going to love it you're going to
take care of it right you you foster
dogs right yeah you're going to put them
in a better environment what does love
do yep
right so when men talk about love
once again people are going to confuse
it with weakness and or kindness or soft
spot and hey
if people feel that way i just say you
know i challenge you to look at the
ancient philosophers and say what's the
longest man a road will travel it's from
his head to his heart and once you spend
a little bit more time in your heart and
you make yourself available to other
people and you invest in other people
your happiness just grows exponentially
yeah man and it but but like kev you
know i i think it really is going to
take
men like yourself
you know and all the people
but
everyone's got everyone's got these
traumas and there's so many [ __ ]
forces at play that tell you to keep
that [ __ ] bottled up and judgments and
and i feel again
it's it's this rah-rah chest-beating
[ __ ] fake projection of strength
from people who haven't actually
been in the
the models aren't out there man well you
know i
like maybe it's the silent majority
whatever it is but i i know that there
are millions of men out there right now
that are far back far better human
beings vastly you know better because of
their wives of course right where are
our wives of course right they're
heart-centered creatures that are so
loving and so present yeah and put us in
check all the time
it doesn't make us weak nope makes us
better 100 makes us more present yeah
it's more available for our sons and our
daughters and our friends there's those
balancing forces right so
you know i think that that's you i'm
just part of my journey and and my
studying into warrior cultures and the
the ascension you know of of the man
yeah you look where it all ends
and you just aspire to be a better human
being you know it it and those virtues
are always at the top of benevolence and
love and charity and
and kindness yeah
just studied the samurai bushido yeah
you know once you sent it well you've
gone to war right you've been this
warrior
who has honed his craft yeah and his
code is archery and
his short sword and his long sword yeah
right he's become so proficient in
warfare but now it's his duty to pro
practice calligraphy and poetry
right and sit in stillness and it's his
duty to develop a relationship with
nature
but you know as he continues to develop
then where does he land well now you're
the teacher
and now that you've found peace and
balance in your life it is your duty
to the community to the sons and
daughters of that community to develop
the whole human being not
just that one tool you used to be in
warfare of course of course
now let's develop the heart let's
develop the mind yeah right and then
let's pass it on
that's beautiful man and so
i mean talk about uh
let's uh let let's talk about trace for
for for a second man let's talk about
like
i mean you're you're uh right here yeah
i mean you're
you know man i think i think you and i
are are
are really uh we're really aligned in in
that man she's very affectionate she's
very loving and she's always
got her eye on the prize
the moment is now
you know and and men can live here
right we can be in our heads we should
be all over the place of course we could
be in the future we can be in the past
what have i done what do i need to do
right we're always in that kind of that
planning survival mode
and that grounding force comes and goes
hold on a sec
get on the ground spend some time with
your daughter that's right right that's
right and there's there's so much beauty
in that yeah i feel like you're so right
yeah yeah yeah right and and to be there
um and to
um to have that in your life i think is
invaluable yeah yeah talk about
you know now having a a daughter and
that journey and and just beautiful zazi
and and and you know what
what that's done for you and and um
and how that um
how that makes you think about the world
i'm gonna exercise my right here and say
how does it make you feel
i don't know i i i see so much i like my
my kids like just give me like so much
uh hope you know like there's no journey
that i'd rather
be on than the the journey with them you
know and uh
i i i know that this is a job that i'm
gonna [ __ ] up uh i'm i know that it's
job i'm gonna do
my absolute best in and and and i
you know it's it's the thing that i can
say i'm i'm approaching
with like absolute clarity and honesty
you know like i i just want to be with
them by their side and say hey
this is what this is what daddy thinks
this is where i screwed up this is how
you're going to do better everything
every single thing is is is is through
them and about them honestly man the
only reason i'm i'm i'm here trying to
do this i'm very worried about the world
man i'm very worried about the state of
discourse and and how far apart we are
um i'm i'm i'm very
afraid and and disappointed in in in the
division and that is like not how i
[ __ ] live my life that is not how my
family's gonna live their life um
and so i think that like you know we we
do we have to
be there for them and be with them and
guide them and get their back and
provide and support and protect them but
we also have to do our part i think
in
eliminating some of this [ __ ]
division and trying to bring people
together any way we can
um so i i think you know anyway that's a
long-ass answer no short-ass question no
it's um it's beautiful you know it's
you know knowing you growing up with two
brothers like myself coming from an
all-male family um
to um and my wife and i we we tried to
have um children for seven years
seven years of fertility
um
and watching my wife go through the ups
and downs of miscarriages and
pregnancies that don't take
and her spirit
um through the whole thing
um
[Music]
her emotional constitution through the
whole thing [ __ ] what a source of
strength in the household
she was really the strong one through
the whole thing and i had kept hey how
are you doing babe are you okay okay
and
it was you know her experience is up
until the very end i'm not listening to
doctors anymore i'm going to follow my
own roles this is the way i want to do
it
she had already been through a lot
we get pregnant
we we knew we're going to have this
daughter and i don't know if i shared
this with you but
when we talk about women and we talk
about strength
my wife um
you know gave we had a cesarean my wife
gave birth
um we go into recovery and then my wife
uh started hemorrhaging really bad
um that all started when the nurses were
handing our daughter back to my wife um
to bond and
one of the nurses picked up on her
really quick and said hold on a sec like
she looked at tracy she said
do you want do you want your daughter
and theresa said no i want to sleep
that's not a normal response so the
nurse ripped back the sheets and my wife
was bleeding profusely
so here i'm bearing witness all this
they rip all the cables out of the wall
they wheel my wife into surgery she
spends the next hour and a half and by
the grace of god
on a sunday the reproductive
oncologist happened to be in the
hospital
um so the laborist the ob gyn could not
stop the bleeding
he comes in um and saves their life
um and my wife goes into the icu for the
next three days
so i'm bouncing between the nursery and
the seventh floor with the nurses like
honestly like kevin like go be with your
wife like we're gonna take care of your
daughter um
and the kindness that the nurses showed
me
and the reassurance that they gave me
and then i go down and spend you know
days with my wife who's in a coma
um
she was on this ventilator and they
tried to see whether she could tolerate
removing her office ventilator
and in the process she couldn't tolerate
it so okay here we go again like she's
still in her coma
and
just before they removed her innovation
tube and we're gonna take her off the
ventilator as they
continue to give her blood
um and her fluids um and essentially
keep her alive um she became more and
more cognizant more conscious
and
her first instinct because my wife can
sign her first instinct was
when she woke up and she looked at me
was you know she's like i want to speak
i have this tube in my throat she kept
doing this and doing this and
a really profound moment um
she realized she couldn't speak she's
just like i'm gonna sign so she starts
to sign to me she starts to spell
zazzy's name
she's like is she okay that was her
first instinct
you know what i mean like
powerful moment and
the power of a mother who's been a
mother for days right for that all to
kick in yeah man
it was insane yeah
but that has carried over into many
facets of our life you know and
those moments and appreciating we're
alive we're together we've been through
a lot um
she gives
everybody every ounce of love she
comes across stranger um or family
and you know it's a gift that she got
from her own family her family is such a
source of strength and
wonderfully bonded um
and has been through a lot in their own
lives yeah um
from
civil rights era
and lack of opportunity i think it's
very easy for
americans to look through the lens of
well
the constitution has been written the
laws are what they are it's an even
playing field go out there and get it
it's not an even playing field if you
understand that um
hope
um has eroded
under the strain
of cultural and political
um
oppression
you know uh
of 400 years of slavery yeah of jim crow
laws
of my father
who couldn't buy a home in his first
professional career
he wasn't allowed to buy a home you know
you you talk about with your family
to provide protect but make it better
for them that it was for you that's what
we're charged as families well he's not
allowed to buy a home
to create generational wealth
right
that's one aspect of how these families
have been affected um so you know we
come to a crossroads in an america that
sits in an era of
what we were talking earlier abundance
and
um creature comforts and ease
and with a flick of a button you could
get something at your doorstep in the
next two days
and our conveniences are everywhere
um and that doesn't exist uh that just
doesn't exist for everyone in america
and if you love your country and you
love um you know certainly our veterans
and you love our military and you have a
deeper sense of compassion
for those veterans that are going
through tough times when they do come
home because they serve their country i
just ask your audience to you know to
um take that gaze and apply that same
sense of compassion for a community
um that has suffered for hundreds of
years
and become a student and learn and open
your hearts to how they may not have had
the same opportunities as everybody else
and look
it's going to take all of us
there is injustice in this country we're
not perfect we're a beautiful country it
is a wonderful country
but
we
will be so much stronger if we if the
strengths and our civic bonds were so
much tighter
but that takes
you know effort look at the demographics
of people serving this country
right 13 of america is
black
27 of the army is black
that should hit home for a lot of people
and then you look at um other ethnic
groups that are serving this country so
people really need to understand the
sacrifices people are making to afford
themselves a better opportunity in life
through education
um to grow as individuals in the
military and to serve a country that
they love
right so yeah we should be taking care
of our veterans
um
and when it comes you know from my
perspective and what i've learned
through my family
is it's your turn to listen
pay attention
this continues to happen and if you look
at history it's your duty as an american
citizen to reevaluate really evaluate
what's been happening and look at the
beautiful parts of our history
and look at the ugly parts of our
history we are what we are
and if you want to become a better human
being going back to investing in other
people and taking other people on your
wing and cultivating them and being a
part of your community and strengthening
those bonds in your community i think
you want to be a leader
show some humility and step in and get
in uncomfortable conversations with
people from the black community
and listen
and be open to a different narrative
you know be open to
um
[Music]
other people's suffering
and
you want to make this country stronger
you might not be able to serve this
military but you can certainly make some
effort
and stepping forth and stepping in the
ring and getting in there with people
who have less than you do
who need help i think it's really
interesting because you know the
argument that people
use uh sort of against what you know
kaepernick's action and the idea of
kneeling and now when you look at the
nba and you look at this entire movement
is that it's anti-military or it's
anti-american and specifically
anti-military and against the the folks
that have gone and served and died for
this country and um what are your
thoughts on that
i work at an environment where
my whole life people are very patriotic
you know there's flags
in every fire station and in front of
every fire station or painted on the
walls
um having a lot of friends that are in
law enforcement i flags are on cars
obviously
starting my young adulthood in my
careers in the military i hold the flag
near and dear to my heart
um
you know
exercising my own self-mastery
um and some restraint
um
my initial reaction to kaepernick was
i don't agree with what's happening
right now
but
i'm gonna take pause
and
i really started to evaluate
you know his gesture
and i started to evaluate
how long
he decided
to
to take a knee
um and who he consulted with and he
consulted with veterans he consulted
with a lot of people
this was a hasty act
and you know the way i look at it
and being a part of a black family in
the united states
is
i broke it down to this is
if you look at kneeling
as a gesture
when do we kneel
we kneel when we propose to our wives
we kneel in church to pray to god
right we kneel to surrender
right
um we're availing ourselves
we're not pissing on the flag we're not
burning the flag like we see all over
the news in different parts of the hard
hit worlds where they want to vilify
america
he's not pissing on the graves of
veterans
he's asking he's on his knees and he's
asking america to pay attention
it's an emotional subject um
and
you know once you on
once you dip your toe and a greater
understanding of what's happening in
this country
um
and
certainly
bearing witness to the stories of uncles
and aunts and fathers and mothers
that i've
shared a lot of time with
you can't help but feel a deeper sense
of compassion
um
that gesture to me
was simply
please pay attention
and if you go down the rabbit hole and
you listen to people like brian
stevenson
who went on ted talk
he had a presentation on ted
and i think it's one of the most
listened to
uh presentations on that whole platform
uh about
social and racial injustices and as it
relates to incarceration rates
sentencing rates expulsion rates of of
young african-american children for the
same crime for the same misdemeanor
whatever it is
more times sin argue
it's it's the severest form of penalty
for the same infraction would be for a
white person
you hear this
and then you start looking into
statistics you apply that to
um what you bear witness to in your life
and it's going to open you up as a human
being
and
you
you can't help but feel
um
a sense of i've got to do something
you know i've got to be a part of
something i've got to support something
bigger than myself and make people aware
uh i can't have these conversations all
the time in the firehouse because
people are so quick to say i'm not going
to watch football i'm not going to watch
basketball i'm not going to watch this
sport because of the kneeling and it's
just you know they're disrespecting what
is that it's not disrespecting the flag
right i think it's a very reactionary
way to look at i'm just going to choose
a side here okay so but what is the act
of saying i'm no longer going to watch
football i'm not going to watch
basketball how how would you how would
you do how would you describe that act
um you know
for me it's uh it's a very simple way of
looking at a problem
you know it's
it's a very complex problem
right and i think it's unfair
i think it's very very unfair to the
issue it's like let's get ugly let's get
uncomfortable
you know what i mean let's let's
exercise isn't that literally the
definition of cowardice to say okay i'm
just not even gonna i'm just gonna walk
away from this like here's an issue
here's somebody sort of
putting in front of my face saying hey i
have i i have a problem here and i'm
taking a stand and you're saying okay
i'm walking well if you're going to take
a stand i'm turning my back on you i
mean i can't think of a more un-american
act than that well i you know i don't
necessarily look at it as cowardice i
look at it like
people are trying to be patriotic
for their own reasons and they're
standing up for what they think is right
how is that american kev to say but but
those those ideas need to be challenged
right you're right and and there's time
and place to challenge it i can't
disrupt a fire station at work by saying
hold on i'll stop we're going to get
into a philosophical argument and a
historical argument right now oh and by
the way we have to provide the community
with what they need on a given notice
that's heavy that's a conversation over
a beer outside of work and say look we
you know
meet my wife
right
and if you have it within you yeah have
some conversations with her yeah
and difficult conversation successful in
that
to a certain degree yes have i lost i
have i lost some friendships over the
issue yes um you just take a stand in
life you hope you could do what you need
to do but
i can't walk away from other people
because i can't help but have that image
burned in my mind of dr dr martin luther
king sitting with lbj in the white house
right it's like the only way we're going
to heal the only way we're going to get
better is if we have these open
conversations and these uncomfortable
dialogues with one another to say
we need to be better educated we need to
look at this from a different lens it
has been grossly unfair to a massive
cross-section of america and if we're
going to be a stronger nation
truly and we're going to eradicate the
hopelessness in certain communities
and impoverished communities if we can
lift them out of those circumstances
you know this this country will be
vastly stronger
and and there's layers to that right how
do we do it um when do we do it um i'll
leave that to much smarter people than
myself but it's gonna start with
let's let's get into it man yeah that's
it that's it and and meet my wife and
let's have the conversation i mean
because i look i can understand why
saying okay look man like let's look at
the let's look at the data points and
kaepernick talked to nate boyer who's a
green beret and this was all done like
you said it was done with thought it was
done with conviction this wasn't this
wasn't just some brazen nobody was
pissing on anything but i also think you
as someone who's who who has served and
fought for this country i i think you
standing up and saying hey listen you
know like
i'm okay with this you know i i
understand explore the issue you know
get into it um
challenge your own way of thinking
what you're saying in terms of your
training you know and
and to be
sort of an elite soldier it's all about
getting uncomfortable it's about
learning it's about growth that you got
you have to experience some [ __ ] pain
you have to you have to get you you got
to sleep deprivation no food like get
[ __ ] up learn about yourself depend on
the guy next to you learn what you can
get from that guy what you can how you
can be there for that guy as much as
you're uncomfortable in your own mind
body and spirit get uncomfortable with
your ideas that's it you know and and
you know deconstruct your own thoughts
about different things and critically
think and you know if you're really
unsure
you know take that massive leap and it
may change you it may not but that's one
step keep going and keep diving into it
and then you know
what have you done you've developed a
relationship with something maybe you
developed a friendship with something
maybe you've changed your way of
thinking about something maybe you vote
from yourself up to a lifelong
friendship that's right right either way
you're enriching yourself that's right
and and i and i think that that that
would be a beautiful thing
you know it's um
we need more of it
100
if you if you could change anything
about uh the discourse of this country
or uh what what what would it be
oh well i you know
since we're on the topic you know when
you think about
uh the first amendment everyone loves
that first amendment right um
before you get too self-righteous about
your opinions about things
know that
that i think that there was divine
intervention in that room with our
founding fathers they debated for months
and months and months to create a
wonderful document that set the
foundation for this very country it's
you know
and that first article right it talks
about the freedom of speech
that
yeah exercise your freedom of speech but
don't lose respect for one another
and if someone has a varying opinion or
a difference of opinion
doesn't mean you should lose love or you
know
a sense of compassion for them or a lack
of understanding for them
it's say you know what maybe it's time
to break bread right if you're on the
left call up your conservative friend
let's let's go to dinner and if we have
it out we have it out yeah but at the
end of it just like boxers do or guys in
the ufc and they've lost their teeth
they're gonna go share a beer afterwards
and they're gonna laugh and say agree to
disagree
you know it's it's all good i love you
you know we love this country we're not
gonna disagree on that yeah um but build
some bonds yeah yeah
i just think that we all have to be our
authentic selves
uh in the end and
i know i'm gonna piss a lot of people
off in this conversation out there um
but again i asked them it's like
um
pass your own sniff test
can i ask you kev what do you what do
you think that you've said
uh that's gonna piss people off oh about
the gesture in kaepernick it's such a
divisive issue once once it was labeled
as you hate america and that became
circulating at that
well the media is perpetuating it these
corporations that know that they can
capitalize on the anger of fear of
americans that are very very frustrated
when
americans have nothing to do but be
grateful at the abundance that we have
um we are not becoming some communist
nation we are not becoming some ultra
right christian orthodox you know nation
from the 16th 1500s and you know what
makes us [ __ ] great is where
everything dude yeah because we're
[ __ ] everywhere we have a lot of good
people like the people in the foreign
affairs offices you know um and you know
in their political
uh positions overseas are so very so
they're so well educated yeah um they're
amazing diplomats for the for the most
part right yeah um we have a lot of good
people doing a lot of great work the
teachers without borders the teachers
core the usaid all of the work that
we're doing overseas is because we're so
abundant and because we can afford to
here's our bounty we're sharing it with
you now as individuals let's embrace
that as it is what we're doing as a
nation but do it as individuals here's
my bounty i'm sharing it with you right
and watch what happens to your life
right you know what i mean right you're
going to grow right
it's going to be an amazing experience
right i i do remember
you know the journey that that that you
and trace went on with being being
parents and me and aaron both said
there's
no two people that
need to be parents more than you guys
and i i do believe that um you know
she's
you know i i just i love you man and i i
love your family and uh i'm just i'm
super grateful i'm super grateful i'm
humbled to be here thank you
yeah thank you so much and
you've been a huge source of inspiration
for me um
not knowing much about performance art
or actors
i dipped my toe into help a director in
a couple small projects i really
didn't understand it
and certainly walking on to a project
like fury
with shia yourself and brad and and
logan and mike pena and
it was it really blew me away
and really developed a
a respect for people that were artists
like that was my first real time i think
i saw
artists at work
movies being movies and it's a massive
moving machine and it's very quick i
didn't develop relationships with too
much and one project saw a tremendous
amount of ego
and i was maybe this isn't for me
but to be able to develop relationships
um
with with you you know on that set
um and see how hard i and i think that a
lot of americans
um
don't know or can't appreciate how hard
like the artists work at their craft
and telling these very very important
stories and
it was an incredible experience um
you know and so much is blossomed out of
that yeah
so all i can do is be your cheerleader
from the sidelines brothers
keep up the good work
um keep telling the truth and the great
stories and
you know our family to yours like we
love you and we're always going to be
there for you thank you thank you and we
love america too thank yeah we do we
love america love you america yeah like
all of our heart yeah
[Music]
thanks for being here everybody i really
appreciate it if you dug what you saw
and you want to hear more subscribe like
do all that stuff uh it'd mean a lot to
us i hope you dig these episodes as much
as we dig doing them you guys take care
of yourself